the athletes luxury home is a shell now
cleared of all his belongings including
his medals and running trophies a silent
empty reminder of the event which
changed his life forever
and violently cut short his model
girlfriends the athletes bedroom seems a
lot smaller somehow without all his
possessions and this is the corridor he
headed down gun in hand towards the
bathroom
it was here he told police he heard
noises coming from behind the toilet
door noises he insists he believed were
made by an intruder the four bullets the
runner fired through the locked toilet
door ended the life of reeva Steenkamp
who was behind it just what the athlete
was thinking when he picked up his
9-millimeter pistol formed the backbone
of the long-running trial police
photographs taken hours after the
shooting showed the runner drenched in
his girlfriend's blood which version
will the judge decide on will she
believe the prosecution's version that
the athlete chased his girlfriend down
this corridor and into the bathroom
where she barricaded herself in the
toilet and he deliberately fired four
shots intending to kill her or will she
believe the athletes version that he was
so unstable on his stomps he had to lean
here and after fear for his life
and his girlfriends he fired towards the
toilet cubicle believing that his life
and his girlfriends was at risk the
athlete was in the witness box for seven
days insisting he never intended to kill
his girlfriend Lauren stood up to the
door sort of hitting that side and I
think I had it three times from the door
open I threw it open and I set over Eva
and I cried
along
mr. Pistorius but the prosecution solved
differently I made a mistake
you killed leave us can't come that's
what you did I made a mistake you see
you're repeating it three times what was
your mistake
you killed her you shot and killed it
work you take responsibility for that
my lady that's how you think say yes I
killed I shot and killed three versed in
God took my lady
okay the toilet cubicle still bears the
scars of the shooting the yellow
stickers were placed there by the police
the athletes house has now been sold
everything packed up and moved out the
Pistorius family say he could never face
living in the house again but he also
had to raise funds to pay for his very
expensive legal costs but this house
will be forever remembered for what
happened in the early hours of
Valentine's Day 2013
Alex Crawford Sky News Pretoria